nice
okay we are taking a look at a new
symbolic testing framework
that is supposed to be an update of
verification tests and related functions
is that correct
yep
so basically this is an ongoing effort
of yeah an internal group um that and
and we are trying to to build over the
existing designs so the main
uh Challenger is to basically build and
improve a system while maintaining
backward compatibility so this was um
one of the main challenges here
um the problem with the existing test
Suite I mean the the testing framework
we are right now it's uh it's it's very
straightforward meaning that uh you know
it just works in most cases but at some
point you you're gonna eat the wall when
basically you need to do something more
more complicated
uh the main problem boils down to
uh test creation and execution that are
um together inside the function you were
mentioning verification test
um and so basically we have been working
on splitting those two steps
um another issue is that you you most of
them you want to store that belari
metadata while executing a test so for
example you want to capture your system
um ID or your kernel ID or other things
uh inside the test and then take
decisions with that later
um
and then basically what we want to be
able to do in more advanced scenario uh
is that you want to do test processing
and control evaluation so you want to be
able to process test in real time as
soon as they are evaluated uh because
most of the time when you're testing it
can happen that you know a tester is
actually killing your kernel so you need
to know uh exactly at what point things
were failing you want to change the
control flow
um when certain conditions are happening
uh you want to be able to create this
from existing tests filtering disabling
automatically inject code
um all those rules should be able to you
know you should be able to
to decide what to do based on custom
metadata that you are uh creating and
storing uh you want to be able to run
tests in different order
um rendering parallel or or Divine on
you know a custom
um basically graph of test and then
decide which part needs to be executed
and now now the obviously we are not
solving all this problem especially like
this but we are providing the the the
the building blocks in order to to do
them in the future
uh so how we're doing it the way we're
doing it is to
um basically we're introducing a new
function that is called test create that
allows you to create an inner test that
you can then evaluate using another new
function that is called test evaluate
then we have meta information option
that allows you to capture the
environment
um there is a new test evaluation
function option
um for test report that allows you to
choose how to evaluate a test if you
want to evaluate it at all
and then we have under functions
an Android functions key which is
another existing system that exists in
other parts of the system that we are
adapting here in order to basically
respond and react uh to event in real
times
so let's start with something easy like
this is um we're also building a
progress reporting option that defaults
to true in uh in a notebook
and um and yeah you can see the behavior
so basically now we have finally a
progress report that shows how many
tests are have been around why did this
evaluate something there's no test
evaluate here
no here no here I'm just showing the the
press the progress report but test
report will automatically create uh
evaluate non non-evaluated tests
and this is the good NPA here so when
when you run a test report test Suite is
uh is evaluated
I got it yeah nice okay
uh then we have under function cylinder
function key so this is just simple test
file I have
um and so
um by default you you have an
association that says an Android event
and then you specify a function so what
to do with it
um wait
yeah
so those are all the events that are
printed so you see that every time so
the Bible started then a certain file
was open uh then section started their
test was created and then at the end the
test is evaluated so as a final step so
first we collect the test and then the
test is evaluated
now you can with Android functions you
can say that you only want to print
events
for example when a test is evaluated you
want to print it
and with under function keys you can
select only the keys you are interested
into so that you you don't get them all
with this function for example you can
you can react to any event the function
is executed during the the evaluation of
test rewards so for example you can use
throw and catch
in order to
to throw an error
if the outcome of a certain test
was was not a success and so you can
immediately stop the test suite for
example
[Music]
um
so I was I was speaking about the fact
that we we were trying to minimize
backwarding compatibility so this
changes uh is optional this is the only
backward thing compatible change
uh but I think it's necessary because
what we have done is that
um when you do test create uh basically
it will create uh what we call now a
test object and previously it was called
test result object with a new outcome
that is called not evaluated
and uh so basically the test object we
now have five different outcomes those
are the four existing this is the new
one
um and so basically that's the result
object will simply evaluate to this
object in the in this design it is a
little odd to me that those those things
not evaluated as a state of a different
kind than success and failure I don't
understand why there isn't I mean it's
not the right name but an unevaluated
test object object that is created by
test create
well as I was saying like that that that
would probably would have been a good
solution if we were designing is from
scratch but
um but but this is a design that that
tries to to live with the with the
existing system
test Creator is a new function right
so it can create anything at once so
where's the plugin with the existing
system
how does it plug with the existing
okay so basically when you do when you
um so basically the test object just
just replaces the test result object uh
you can feed it to test result to test
the report and test report will take
care of evaluation
otherwise you can simply evaluate with
test evaluate so basically I don't
understand why there's a problem here so
the existing thing is not as soon as you
generate verification tests it will
evaluate and that gives a test results
object which is the result of the
evaluation right which is then reported
on by test report correct correct okay
all right so you're saying test create
creates an unevalued you know we have
this term verification test
which is an evaluated test
that gives a test object as its output
correct so basically in this in this
design that that I have done
um basically verification test is
identical to this can basically be
replaced
so I understand my test create can't
produce something that isn't the right
name but it's basically an unevaluated
test object well it's
yes is still because then then you will
need to better match in in a different
way depending on whatever is is which is
probably not convenient sorry pattern
match for what so every time you need to
process this you need to check whatever
is a success or a fail or whatever
um right
um
you're arguing okay you're arguing that
it is convenient to have a test object
that can be in an unevaluated State as
well as in a success stated Zone that is
convenient to have the same kind of
construct representing unevaluated the
properties they're going to be common in
any case
um because you know you're gonna have
input and then evaluated case and you're
gonna have input in in the other line
you're not going to know whether you
know the status
okay but in the in that case you're
gonna we are returning as I'm missing
okay so wait a second so the design
Point here is
that you think it's convenient to
conflate together the unevaluated tests
and the evaluated tests in a single test
object am I correct or are you only
doing that for some kind of
compatibility reason
um we are doing it for both reason and I
also think that is convenient also
because like when you have a test object
you want to run it again so if you have
a test object that that was failed
in any case you want to be able to just
take that object
and run test evaluate in order to to see
you know if now it works okay so
so basically it's just a state where
okay so if you have a test object that's
successful can you say test evaluate
again on the successful test object yes
so test evaluate will always run a test
object that's the that's the design
there is no incompatible change other
than the fact that this guy was called
test result object
so basically so verification test
previously gave a test results object
and you're proposing that it now gives a
test object yes both test results object
and test object can be fed to test
report as elements to produce a report
yeah
exactly
because we think that in the end test
result object would be confusing for the
non-evaluated case
um yeah I got it I got it this makes
sense keep going okay
um so what we were saying okay yeah
other functions we've done uh test
object test create yeah so okay so this
was the change we tested object yeah I
got it
yeah so task test evaluate will always
evaluate as good as we were saying so
for example if I do
um this test which is basically doing a
random integer as you can see basically
it it will keep evaluating it over and
over again
it starts with in the non-evaluated case
then we apply test evaluate then we
reapply it again and then we apply it
again and so every time it's evaluated
again
it's going to be listable
in this design we can simply double get
verification test
um
or we can keep it as a shintoch sugar
for uh for this
um yeah then then let's go to test
results so um basically the latest robot
works is that test reward evaluates the
the first the first argument
um it will collect all events happen
during the evaluation so everything that
that
every test that is created during the
first argument evaluation will be
collected then it will collect the
results and then basically you know it
will have created at some point a big
bag of test
um what it will do is that it will take
all the all the tests will not evaluated
status
um because for whatever reason what's
the difference between test create and
just test object
the test object you you can create it by
basically a a test object is just an
authorization
um
test create is just syntax sugar to
produce uh the rightest object so you
don't do basically mistake one important
difference also is that test create
essentially sows the test object so if
you have a sequence of test creates in a
file you don't have to somehow
figure out how to return them
okay I don't understand that statement
um so suppose you have a file full of
tests right one after the other and you
want to collect them without evaluating
them
right now verification test and uh you
know they're not returned from a file
they're sewed like
that's really weird yeah like that yeah
this is the existing design so basically
what happens is that you know during the
evaluation of this argument and
everywhere when when we get the files
um there are events so this is a weird
object this is a weird thing you're
saying you're saying
um the so doesn't happen unless the test
create the tests create
I mean
just wrap a reap around that just create
oh no but this is not actually I mean I
cannot
um but but again so that I mean
obviously it doesn't happen so there's
no Auto sewing no no no no obviously
it's tested about that that is
internally using a mechanism similar to
the pencil but it but it's not related
to the pencil okay hold on hold on what
exactly is it doing
I mean you'll say everything is event
based so what it's doing is very simple
remember these Android functions so
every every time uh there is test create
test create evaluates in the mid
sentiment
um that's rewards simply relax event
and it creates a report out of this
event
that's okay hold on hold on hold on hold
on I'm trying to understand this
okay
so
you've got this whole piece of code and
it's got all kinds of deeply nested
things
and you're saying that I mean explain to
me how this relates to like things like
confirming clothes which also are sort
of action of distance functions
is this the same thing if I run a test
evaluate if I say let me just understand
if I say test report of f of
test evaluate of test create what
happens could you try that please
report off yeah make that bigger could
you make that notebook
yeah of f of no no Open Bracket please
please let's do it that way up and
bracket F of
test create
of some random test
all right show me what happens here
so yeah I mean so what happens is that
it will as I was saying so first of all
this guy evaluates so it will collect
the event and you will have inside the
test report this event now we are
encountering here an invalid expression
that is f of test object whatever and
test report is complaining I don't
understand why are there two parts here
why isn't test report just collecting
the evaluated output of the test
evaluation of test create
um this is not something that I mean
this is this is part of the Legacy
Behavior
the Legacy Behavior what what test
report is already doing in the system
this is not something new but I can
explain to you so basically what what
what what is happening is that every
time test create evaluates so every time
there is a verification test because it
was verification test uh every time
verification test evaluates it emits an
event and the event is basically yeah
repentable so basically every time I got
it I understand implementationally
what's happening okay I get it okay okay
the problem is that
what does it return from the evaluation
you're saying that test so I don't
understand
this
did this or did this not generate a
valid test report object
this is returning a value tested about
object and this test is going to be
inside your test report okay fine there
is also one failure that is happening
because after the evaluation of this
result basically this reward will
so if you
um we will pass the the result of the
expression and the result of this right
why is it doing it twice why is it
picking it up both from the so and from
the evaluated form
um because if you you can fit to test
report a list of already evaluated tests
and simply do the do the report
so it's not cutting up for me no no no
no no no no no so if you have one point
is that you're trying to get in real
time you're trying to get a test report
to build things up in real time that's
why you're using so but then you also
are trying to get an output of value
that happens not in real time is that
correct yes but this is not part of the
yeah but this is
this is already the Legacy Behavior so
what what I'm saying is that you can do
this and this is basically yeah
functionality of testing Can somebody
understand Todd do you understand what's
going on here what Connor do you
understand this well I think I'm not
probably
go ahead I'm sure I think
yeah I mean I think it would help to
understand the motivation for why this
so Behavior exists at all and my
understanding and you know what is borne
out and how we use this internally our
testing Frameworks is you have a file
that's full of tests right yep and if
you want to Simply you know write out a
sequence of tests one after the other
it's extremely poor user experience if
you have to essentially manually collect
the results of each of those tests and
then make sure the last statement in
your file is returning that
um so that's the ux motivation for why
that's so Behavior I might say so I'm
sorry this is just a hack
come on guys that's not the right way to
solve that problem
if you've got to test a file of tests
and you want to you know look look
okay what you're saying is notebook
evaluate on that file of tests notebook
evaluate has the behavior that it is
producing the last the last result in
the notebook okay that might not be the
right behavior and in this case it's not
the right Behavior instead you want to
pick up every single output it's like a
notebook import am I making sense
yeah
right you really want notebook import
not notebook evaluate
but the solution to that is not to have
some crazy action at a distance so reap
thing which doesn't make any sense in
the okay does it make any sense except
for that case
because I think that case you're solving
in the wrong way
so is there any other case where it
makes sense
is there some real-time Behavior where
it makes sense
well I think the emission of events
certainly makes sense I mean for things
like progress reporting and you know
printing out test results generating
events is a different thing yeah but
this so reap behavior is not the same
thing the events are fine and dandy
yeah but basically what what we have
done is to I mean this is against you
and this is the Legacy Behavior we we
have
a lot of system that that rely on this
Behavior so
um okay I'm not buying it I'm sorry I
think it's wrong so let's yeah I I also
think it's wrong
here's how we do the design okay let's
figure out what we want
let's figure out how we want it to work
then let's take the Legacy behavior and
let's make a bridge but first let's
figure out what we want and not pull
back from what we want saying oh my God
it might be a not compatible Legacy wise
okay let's figure out what we want first
then we'll talk about how we make a
bridge Legacy Behavior okay well I I I I
think that it that it wouldn't affect
the the design that we have because
if we remove this this this this this
evaluation Behavior where we're
basically collecting also the desk that
yeah that are different let's get some
evaluation let me just understand
it's okay the so behavior is used only
so that you can take a notebook full of
tests is that correct
and what do you do with that notebook
um go ahead it's it's not a notebook
already let's not use that word right
because we're not talking about we're
talking about a file okay so what do you
do with that file how do you activate
that file how do you say run the tests
in this file
so you basically do test report of that
file okay fine fine so test report of a
file
you're saying that that test report of a
file because of some implementation
detail was God this is crazy it's crazy
I'm sorry it's just crazy you're saying
that it was doing you thought that that
had to use get which means that it could
only read the last thing in the file but
there's no reason why test report of a
file shouldn't work like import of a
file where it can do whatever it wants
with the file it doesn't have to just
read through the file and pick up the
last element in the file am I making
sense
right you could get every every
independent input line essentially yeah
it's perfectly valid for test report of
a file to just say I'm going to go
through this file I'm going to pick up
every test and I'm going to run it
does that make sense Ricardo I mean am I
messing something here
but there's but there's others this is
the existing like but there can be other
typical test Suite that we have that are
not changed though right and and if you
just get this file
we don't want to just get that file we
don't want to do that we want to say how
we want a function that no just getting
the file won't work
right it's not what we want
when when you say run tests that you're
trying to have a hacker you know
hakalola where you say just running get
will run the tests that's not correct
see what I'm saying the action of
running tests is a different thing from
just running get that's why you've gone
to all the trouble to separate out test
create from test evaluate
the previous version said
naming a test runs the test you've
pointed out that that's wrong
am I making sense
yeah
and so it's wrong in this case as well
you don't want the pure get to run the
tests you want some wrapper to run the
tests wait wait wait no get will not run
the desk because this guy will will
basically just create it right so so
okay and it weighs it and it will just
immediate after the test was created
then test report that is listening to
this event will collect them and run
them at the end okay but so then the
correct thing is that you're given a
file and the file is fed to test report
and test report picks up the tests in
the file it goes through the file just
like import it goes through the file it
looks for the tests in the file Picks
Them Up it you know runs them or
collects whatever is coming from them
and then everything is happy
there's no issue there's no hack about
oh my gosh it's only the last line but
it's it's basically the same
implementation so you are saying that we
should instead of relying on evaluation
we should pass this file
well so I think I mean you could imagine
the way you'd approach this because I
you know there are probably other types
of files than testing files where it'd
be useful to get all of the non-last
results as well right so you can imagine
we could have a system function
placeholder name you know get all or you
know an option to get that's like
include non-last results obviously
terrible names but that's the idea
um
yeah
um and that would be the building block
on which you'd build I mean you
essentially just do get list of file.mt
and then you do cases of that to look
for test objects and maybe you know
lists that that just won't work for for
more complex cases because I want to be
able to to generate uh uh test you know
based on an algorithm I want to do while
through and do test create that's that's
basically the
um you're not going to be able to use
get for these files off the table right
so you're going to have a wrapper that
takes the file that contains tests and
runs those tests
am I making sense
right well hey that that wrapper is test
report it's just a question of fine what
does it look like at the intermediate
steps well there's no I mean how it's
implemented is irrelevant the the
all I'm saying is
okay are you explaining this so reap
thing to me just as a piece of
implementation or does it have a user
consequence
um no I mean we we we I mean the the
user consequence is that basically every
time you you evaluate this create during
this blog
um we are collecting this test
automatically
I don't understand I don't understand
inside test report just like in close
for example looks for every confirm
inside that enclosed
and it doesn't look for them no I mean
confirm I mean confirm just does
something and it throws to the outer
enclose and you're saying you're doing a
similar thing here with test report is
that correct yeah there's no problem
with that
there's no consequence I mean it there's
no user consequence nothing the user
will ever see
I mean it's just that am I am I am I
wrong here I mean yeah no I I don't
think that that is uh I mean again if we
were designing this from scratch maybe
we would have got a different a
different decision but I don't I don't
understand I don't understand
this is purely implementation right
make sure that I understand so in that
first case there
no no no no no no your test report TR
equals test report there this one here
okay
so
that's running those tests with that
test evaluation function okay and what
does it produce as output can I see the
output ah yeah so the output is going to
be a test report object with um great
that's exactly what I would have
expected no problem yes now if you root
test the result here you will see that
basically one of them was executed and
the other one was not because the the
evaluation function is basically
designing okay
there's no problem with this
right okay
um
yeah I mean
what is Mt
uh where where again dot empty file
I think there was a mathematical test
file it should be dot WT presumably
yeah we have both
it's just okay
okay hold on hold on hold on hold on so
test report there is given a list of
strings which are file names is that
correct
um so in this case yes
so this evaluates too okay that I got
here
test report presumably eats
the following objects it eats test
objects it eats strings edits file
wrappers it is cloud objects
Cloud object we can support them yes
yeah we need to be able to do that
so anything that can store an expression
it will support
yeah
okay so now
what it does it takes that file with its
yeah I mean
see a cloud object is already a tricky
case because what's in that file that
file could either be a single expression
with a list of test objects
or it could be a file where there is a
test object on separate lines is that
correct
um yeah I mean I'm um yeah I mean as as
long as the we will basically be doing
Cloud get I guess uh during during the
evaluation I want to make sure that the
thing I just said is correct
in that file there are two choices yes
so it's number one
what's that yes like a regular file yeah
it's a single expression that is a list
of test objects that is one possibility
true or not true
true okay case number two is you want
the special case if there are multiple
expressions in that file that get list
the function we should have had 35 years
ago but didn't okay get list
if get list returned more than one
element
okay get list will be a little bit like
read list
okay
it's it's if it returns more than one
element that means there's more than one
separate expression in that file
so one is saying you could either put
those test objects in a list or you
could put them in on separate lines so
that get list would return them as
different list elements is that correct
yes in the current implementation
basically this works but also in the
Legacy implementation it will work okay
fine so so then
okay I understand so
great that's fine so then typically in a
cloud object you would just have a list
of test Expressions test objects
just because it doesn't really deal with
the multi-line
Story I mean again I'm a little bit
confused by if you have a notebook and
you do a notebook in Port whether you
can have a notebook of test result of
tested objects so as long as you you
know do your thing and then feed test
object inside test reward is gonna work
that's that's the bottom line no no no
no no no no no no no
I'm asking different questions I'm
saying let's imagine that you had a
notebook containing test objects
okay a notebook right it has all kinds
of section headers and texts and all
kinds of other stuff and there is a
particular cell type for example that
contains test objects
presumably that's another case we should
support
we I mean the the the the the test
report is supposed to work with tests
um we with programmatic testing
notebooks
um and yes it means something else
though that's not the same thing as a
because in a programmatic test notebook
test object test create doesn't show up
you just have inputs and outputs in
special cell types
um but you Stephen you're talking about
literally just a notebook that had like
a test created sure it's a good idea
maybe maybe I am talking about that
special notebook testing notebook
maybe that's the right answer for this
right so so the question is does test
report consume
testing notebooks and right and the old
test report did I I assumed it and I
assume this one does too right Ricardo
yeah I know that that yes as I was
saying we are not introducing that kind
of backwarding a compatibility change
yeah
okay
all right I mean I'm I'm good with what
you're showing here I didn't understand
the whole discussion about
I mean the whole discussion about sewing
I just didn't understand it didn't seem
relevant to me it seems like there's a
there's a specific thing which is an
implementation detail about what happens
with a multi-line file which has to be
handled correctly but that's about it
yes and basically the the so mechanism
is we are kind of exposing it with with
this endless function mechanism that
allows you to to react to to every event
um and so every time you see something
you you can decide whatever you want to
okay okay I think this is an
implementation detail I just don't think
it's a user level thing I think we're
not exposing the under function is going
to be a user level thing because yeah
the evaluation of test report
there is a subsidiary call for the
handle functions that's what you're
basically saying right
that's absolutely fine that sounds good
to me
in other words the the test report
tickles the test objects inside and they
start splitting out Handler calls
and that's fine
I mean there's a correct description I
mean rather yeah
um yeah and so um yeah I mean those are
all the notebook that
hold on
okay where's the guide page new guide
page
we haven't touched the get page yet
um but this is something we need to
address all right this looks good to me
I mean am I missing something is there
some giant uh thing that you're not
telling me about no don't ask
no so I mean the the problem Stephen is
that this is again this is like
um yeah I might look kind of
um low level but this is something that
we need in order to build more right
this looks nice to me okay I don't have
any problem with this it looks good it
looks well designed it looks good okay
so can we look at the list of names of
Handler functions and things
um probably a new documentation though
yes I mean under functions also we
haven't touched that part of the
documentation and also the complete
needs to be done
what
possible names of events are there okay
should be everything that you see here
and yes they need to be documented uh
that's true
um
because right now one but there's one
new wrinkle right this unhandled event
thing that is not supported by other
handers
this is this is this is how how it
currently works Android event is the is
the way to go
um but but unhandled event is not in the
other places in the system where we have
Handler functions right they don't
support this unhandled event they do
support an Android event
s
like the URL read if it has a URL submit
and yeah if we go to Handler functions
um
and yeah
there is
yeah so under details here
okay so but isn't there there is
something that we're doing that's a
little new so what I'm doing that is
that I'm not telling you okay
it's just that this is a convenience
this is a convenience for an Android
event and this was a tentative but
actually we were telling you in another
in another place I remember we this came
up somewhere else yes yeah and that if
basically this is a good idea we can
Port it to other places
um but obviously all the documentation
uh and everything for now will be only
mentioning an Android Romantics I I
would have thought that Handler
functions are a print would not mean the
unhandled event it would mean every
freaking event gets print
because after all nothing else is being
handled right well right that's what it
is right every no other right this means
to print every event
yeah
it's the same thing as seeing unhandled
and arrow print as long as you didn't
have any other Hammer functions right I
understand but it's more like all Arrow
print type thing I do think this seems
reasonable so long as what it the
definition of it is
this simply is equivalent to blank arrow
print
am I making sense it is equivalent to
blankets but well if it's not equivalent
to blank arrow print if you have other
Handler functions though right but there
are no other Handler functions you're
saying what all the handle functions are
um just print so basically if you do
this is like if you do so another event
print and then you can do test created
um yeah but right but then you're not
doing the the right but you couldn't say
underscore our print in this Association
no you couldn't no you couldn't that's
that's all I meant but I'm I'm saying
that in the you could have an
association which is just underscore our
print with no test created there
[Music]
right and that would be the same as that
would be the same as just having handle
functions are a print and that seems
just fine to me
right so that's another I don't think
the that underscore Arrow Print
Works that's so important it's okay I'm
just saying conceptually that's what it
is and that's and then I'm fine with
saying handle functions Arrow print
means every every event
gets a
you know it's just operated with you
know has the print as its handle
function
right
okay
all right anything else yeah
um I I actually I'm sorry could you go
back to those event names
so um again I we we we don't ever listen
to documentation I'm not sure where we
should put it because documentation
yes but in the documentation of an
Android function is a generic thing for
um right so you should put it in the
thing for test report I see uh in the
details section yeah and also and what
you can do if you think you're going to
have a whole bunch of these and do you
think that they have non-trivial
documentation per event or not or is it
just once you know the name of the event
you pretty much know what it does or
you're going to have to give more detail
for each of us no for now it's it's
pretty straightforward like but but but
section completed it's going to have a
section name right
um yeah the section is not really
something that we are exposing so this
this is something internal like sections
we don't have them yet okay so let me
let me make a point that we have this
notion of subsidiary documentation pages
so it's like the import stuff has you
know each import format has its own
subsidiary documentation page
right
so if these events are going to Puff out
to being important
then they should have their own separate
documentation pages per event
otherwise put them I would say I would
say have them both on the test object
page
and on the test report page
and we have a good mechanism now for
grandfathering uh you know documentation
from one page to another for these kinds
of things
okay yeah we need to do this table
read-on yeah
okay but I think that there's questions
about the names of some of those event
types
okay I mean the I mean section started
is not user exposed um so we have Rebels
started for now file started test
created
um file completed test evaluated
so this is the moment where you see so
easy what's happening here you got a
test object that is not evaluated
and here you get a test object that was
evaluated
so this is P4 evaluation and after
evaluation
okay but if I already had a test object
there will be no test created event
correct okay
okay
why is it file completed but report
finished
it's well one completed in one finished
uh okay maybe one could be begun and one
could be started but that would be even
more confusing okay
um they should both be completed okay
this is on our yeah this is yeah you're
right yeah okay we can look at other
events that check for other things
whether I don't know whether other
events haven't started completed type
for other events of other Handler
functions right completely different
things
of meat
um yeah
well I gotta look for URL submit here I
task finished
so
everything should be correction I mean
we just yes whatever the created you
know started and finished yes yes yes
yes yes okay it's kind of annoying that
you have to look here in these examples
to see what the event names are there
should be a nice table of event names
somewhere
yeah that I'm not sure this is why I was
asking I'm not sure I'll do it because
under function is generic now for for
multiple function I mean at this point
on the Handler functions page write you
know Handler functions are used in blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
there's like half a dozen functions you
can just list them okay
um then on those individual function
Pages list the events that that
uh that that function can have a Handler
for
eign go to the URL submit page
okay now that presumably has a list of
events scroll down into the details
there we go
following events can be generated
okay right yeah right yeah
a possible key specified by Handler
function keys include blah blah blah I
mean it seems like the right pattern
right right
so this is this is not done in uh in in
the good version of documentation
so that's just fine to me yeah okay what
else
um
not much
we can take a look at individual
documentation Pages
um otherwise it's um yeah I think
try them particular will be well
equipped to be the editor for those
documentation pages and I'm happy to
take a look at them but I think you guys
can do this okay great in fact we've
done some of the editing I don't I don't
claim to have done it all but uh we've
done some editing passes already I think
there's really just just some
examples to add and you know this hand
the function keys stuff to be put in
yeah
you need some workflows are there
workflows about testing right now uh so
there is a guided ink nothing different
from the workflow
I don't know yeah I'm not sure if
there's a work Todd you understand what
I'm talking about yeah we we understand
general I'm not sure the answer to your
question whether there what there is now
of workflows for testing or not yeah
well that probably is
let's go to
okay there is one
okay yeah that's right this one is
entirely about the notebook version no
this is
we'll update this to the yeah right
right that's what I'm saying you need to
update that you probably need to break
it into multiple workflows yeah it's a
run tests from a file run test from a
notebook
yeah makes sense yeah all right so we'll
we'll definitely update that okay I've
got one more thing that you might want
to be able to do and you know you might
want to wfr function at least that
converts between a plain text file of
tests and one of these notebook tests no
testing notebooks
so the notebook when you click on more
here can create the file
um what about a file creating the
notebook yeah we don't have the other
one and I'm that should be rather
straightforward to do I think
that is um ball from function repository
is doing something like that okay fine
fine I mean if it has that I just think
that's a convenience function that'd be
nice to have
all right it'd be nice to go back and
forth yeah yeah
um
this is good now you know in terms of
the use of this
I mean one thing that you do also in the
testing notebook I guess you can you can
say
um
well that that there could be like some
kind of UI where basically you have a
test report in in your in your testing
notebook and and you just convert it to
those kind of cells
yes I know yes but I mean let's just
practical for one second I mean so yeah
you know a good case is wfrs the people
who submit wfrs should generate tests
for them has that been happening now
um so I'm not I'm I'm not super sure but
but I think that inside there's a
mission notebook there is a testing
section right but the question is what
should we tell people to populate it
with okay let me give you some examples
things like that things like the posts
that I write have tons of code in them
which should be turned into tests and I
don't know maybe Stefan can speak to
whether Stefan had to leave here
um uh whether that's happening right now
how that's happening right now and what
that looks like
because do you get what I'm saying
maybe yeah I don't think we know it's
worth another
well another place that comes up is um
it'd be nice if examples of
documentation were also able to be
treated as tests tests rather
yeah
right but also be nice if online we
could say you know what is the good and
test pass for that function
sorry what is the current what what I'm
saying is that if you have a function
that you know we can say that on version
the test pass was 100 but then on on the
new version is 95 well that's the QA I
mean you're talking about for qio or
you're talking about for user level
functions
for user for for for User submitted
function yeah this is not something that
we're gonna um right
it'll be very nice it would also be nice
for apis to be able to do that test
and and we have mapped out a testing
framework for packlets too and encourage
people to okay let's talk about what
Ricardo just writes though because his
his let's talk about how we'd like that
to work
let's imagine that
you
let's assume you're using wfr framework
okay but you might have a private wfr
am I making sense
yeah and you've got tests for it and you
want to be able to press a button that
just says because you might have made a
change to some other function you might
want to say do all my functions still
work you know standard continuous
integration type stuff
so what's the best way to do that
presumably you will have you know you
will have pushed to the cloud your wfi
your private wfr functions am I making
sense
right yeah and you would also have push
to the cloud your testing notebooks
so one of the things that's then
important because you have them in the
cloud it's a persistent storage location
to be able to then just say
uh you know for example to be able to
associate maybe in the documentation for
your for your wfr function
you could have something that will
I think you're going to have to do
something you could do it as a okay
let's talk about two ways to do you
could do it as a scheduled task you just
every day you could run the testing
notebooks and you could spray from the
results of that into the documentation
and you could send yourself mail you
know all the things that tasks can do
you could send yourself mail every day
saying tests are still passing
or you could spray that result into the
documentation for those functions does
that make sense
I think GitHub got some badges where
basically you can embed on a website
that that says you know what is the good
on test pass and so the the you need to
have a URL that that is just an image
with with the test pass
and you can embed it into
yeah
well okay you're saying something
slightly different so you're saying that
given that you have a test a collection
of tests
stored in a cloud object
okay you would like there to be an
Associated result
Cloud object
am I making sense
that's what you basically say given a
cloud given a collection of tests in a
cloud object
you want it to be the case that a
scheduled task is going to come through
for example and generate a corresponding
result Cloud object am I correct
and that result Cloud objects can then
be embedded wherever you want
am I correct
right
okay so the issue is
you know if test report
takes a cloud object as input the issue
is it is not in test report we'll take
Cloud object's input and put in your
current notebook the output from that is
that correct
right
okay so you're saying there's an
additional step which is to say
essentially Cloud export
of or Cloud save
of the results from test report of cloud
objects
right yeah right I mean the test report
is going to be an immutable expression
with all the stuff in it so right so one
additional piece there is if we had
testing notebooks in the cloud
that there'd be a button on that testing
notebook in the cloud that says run this
and put the result in a known Cloud
object
you see what I'm saying
yeah or for all what people care
what I was saying is that from that
notebook you simply have a piece of
embedded code that you can put anywhere
with the result of that the notebook
yeah yeah no no internally
right but the question is what is the
name of the cloud object so given that
you have a cloud object that represents
a collection of tests is there some
standardized name for the cloud that
represents the having the Run version of
those tests
see what I'm saying
right we we would uh need something like
that to
right so that's the thing to
automatically know what that workflow is
I mean my proposed workflow would be
this
given the tests
the the what you do is this
the wfr when you submit it can point to
a test file
okay
typically if you have multiple double A
files they point to the same test file
okay having pointed to the test file
that wfr can then display in its shingle
page the results of those tests
right if there's nothing in that test
file just says there were zero tests and
zero you know whatever happened right as
soon as there's something in that test
file then every so often it will come
through and it will it will get the
results it will put the results from
that test file into a cloud object that
is the that is essentially Daisy chained
from that test file it Daisy trains and
says I'm putting my results In This
Cloud object
okay so in other words the wfr file
points to the the test Cloud object the
test Cloud object points to the result
test result Cloud object does that make
sense
I was just going to say I think that
this is something to really to bring up
in the resource system meetings right
because this is you know infrastructure
that the resource system would be
needing to support
um somehow Connor do you have the last
comment here well just on that topic I
was going to say I mean I I would have
expected that if that's a file that's
linked to from a wfr it shouldn't be
customizable you know by the wfr author
that should just be some standard
location on the wfr itself but yeah I
agree with Todd this is topic for yeah I
agree with that statement too right we
should also think about this for Packers
because that's an idea to have to have
you know be nice to have a little badge
on the pack of single page or green
Banner that says you know no no I agree
yeah we should do it okay this is good
work I did one yes yes last time I had
while we're on the topic of notebooks
and testing there was an idea we
discussed uh about whether a test report
could have a button in line and it's box
you know it's pretty box form that's
like open this as a notebook
so you could have a really easy easy way
why not why not have one of those
buttons we've got an icon for it the
thing with a square with an arrow up
that means sort of openness as a
separate thing
yeah something like that where is this
happening like do you remember in the
output box oh where do we use that
uh it's using a lot of palette type
things it's used in it it's used in the
raft anybody in design Billy or somebody
would know what the Cyclone is okay it's
a square with an arrow
okay do you have another are there any
forms in the language that have that in
their make boxes format
that come up underneath things like if
you do a resource function you just type
resource function
just type it in The Notebook
of I don't know yeah that'd be so that's
the thing that's the puppy
all right cool
okay
it means open up yeah you get what I'm
saying right yeah
um
okay sorry we had one last thing that
was being said you were raising
something else
I know that that was it just okay we
have a button
in the test report object
yeah I mean by the way the things I've
been yakking about about scheduled tasks
require thought
okay I just put that on the list I don't
know who's project managing here who's
project managing here I am Aubry okay
um
I see as a dog I forget
um okay the uh
okay
um let me also point out for ild can we
discuss the get list function and put
that on the agenda please and I need to
run
but this is good it's very nice this is
a simple design review
basically no changes
we're all good
anything I didn't ask anything the thing
I didn't tell you is
we already did that we're good you know
I think that's a good prompt for an llm
that's a good llm prompt the things that
this llm is not telling you are
don't people already do that to extract
like the hidden absolutely absolutely
yeah yes but the retail being very
creative like telling the llm to tell a
story in which some character is going
to explain what the llm would have done
if is it done this and that and the
other to avoid the things that have been
done to protect against discouraging
prompts and so on
anyway Steven you were speaking with a
bot the whole time and you didn't
realize
[Laughter]
all right see you guys later all right
thanks